there's four key things that you have to
focus in on which are your critical
barriers to growth and and these aren't
in any particular order but leadership
number one thing that you need to be
able to do is develop leaders in your
business so if you can't develop leaders
in a recruitment business one of the
things that I sometimes see recruitment
leaders get a bit wrong is they think
scaling a recruitment business is about
hiring lots of great recruiters I don't
actually think that's quite right for me
the number one fundamental thing is that
you have to be able to hire lots and
lots of great recruiters and train and
develop and retain those guys that the
critical piece in that though is that
you have to be able to turn or convert a
high enough proportion of those
recruiters into your Future Leaders if
you can't do that your business won't
scale so first and foremost you have to
be able to identify attracts and bring
into the business either experienced
leaders which is tough unless you know
them already because that you know from
my experience that's a really
challenging to do or you have to be able
to bring in people at the very beginning
of their career give them the skills and
ability to be able to become really
successful recruiters and then the ones
that are suited to and aligned with
leadership you need to be able to
convert a high enough abortion into
leaders I think we did that pretty well
at liquids first and foremost I think we
were quite good bringing people in and
putting them through that conveyor belt
where they went through a constant
Learning and Development program up to
their skills and became you know we have
people in their mid-20s running 40 50
person you know divisions of the
business multi-million pounds huge
profitability wise units of the business
so I think we were quite good at
developing leaders the second thing that
I'd say is really really critical is
scalable infrastructure and if you can't
put in place if you can't identify in
your business what the Core Business
processes are and then put in place
continually reviewed the optimal working
process for all aspects of your business
I think it's going to be really really
tough to scale because you you I think
one of my favorite I think it's from a
book called The e-myth the processes run
the business and the people run the
processes and that always stuck with me
because I think that's really really
true if you look at what business is
business is about having really good
process so if you can't put scalable
infrastructure and good processes into
your business I think you're going to
reach a point where you don't grow
anymore the third thing would be new
business new profitable business if you
can't continually win profitable
business whether from existing accounts
by Landing expanding accounts or by
winning new business and then turning
that into profitable accounts you're not
going to be able to scale your business
because the business is going to starve
and lastly cash flow the fourth thing
I'd say that you've got to be really
really good at is cash flow if you can't
win enough profitable business where
you've got strong enough cash flow to be
able to continually invest in the first
three three things that I described
you're not going to be able to reinvest
back into the business to grow
aggressively enough to keep skating I
think if you look at those four things
we were pretty good at those four things
at liquids and then if you look at those
and put them onto the other side of the
coin they're probably a good starting
point to say well how do I ensure these
barriers don't happen and if you're
doing that you'll probably set yourself
up pretty well to be able to scale the
recruitment mentors podcast is proudly
sponsored by VIN cherry and the
award-winning Source breaker